[Music]
and shocking results news submitted
right technology shocking results news
an electric shock wristband for sale
claims to use a little bit of pain to
zap away bad I don't know probably in
this article this company is called
padlock clever why I said at the same
time some credit from you good job thank
you they're calling it on like fitbit's
evil twin or like the bad cop to the
Apple watch good cop and so it's as
wearable technology that provides a
small electrical shock that's the
creator's say that it will help you curb
your bad habits like smoking oh [ __ ]
smoking biting your nails or not hitting
the snooze button you just like hitting
the snooze button in the morning like in
order like to help you know about
complaining well you just get zapped to
death I know I'm like worried they don't
even eat that oh man you just went boom
for the temple and you could say but how
does it know you're doing bad yeah but
was my that was my question there's a
microphone for example for the nail
biting thing there is like some sort of
technology in that that can feel like if
you're raising your hand what if you're
just itching your nose yeah what if you
smoke you bite your nails anyways yes
now any kind of like this there's no
good that comes from this or this
you're eating just like doing your hair
every no SAP at all does your face yeah
but what about for women you guys are
you guys they were just touching their
faces like I guess why just take it off
the whole time yeah yeah I mean this is
like you have to want to do this you
want to change you want the change yeah
so if you want a few in your church you
wanted it bad enough you wouldn't need
that this is people that understand
their nature mm-hmm okay
so they're like I miss their way of
getting help yes yeah exactly because
like there was this one testimonial or
there was there were three people one of
them didn't want to eat refined sugar
anymore so that's no eating I think it
was a cupcake or something she shocked
herself to like have a negative
association with that Thanks there there
was an old technique like that with a
rubber band knows where our van and you
snap yourself every time you do
something or you think a negative
thought or whatever yeah and so it's
like cheaper yeah that is cheap and this
doesn't work the measurements still had
in half like let me get my rubber band
app yes it's called aversion therapy
version do a version version sir yeah
that's when you flick your kid in the
face right yeah they're doing something
you don't want to do wow they're trying
to ban that a gay aversion therapy
right that's converse conversion avert
the same thing one is like no we're
trying to avert you from the deer
exactly oh so back to those three people
so refined sugar and the Newlin was nail
biting so then that helped her stop
because she said she even tried doing
that nail polish before or even having
like like nails like she still bites her
she bit them off Wow
put your finger in your butthole Thank
You Paulette she just says shitty hand
so shoot somebody and then she does get
sick she got pinkeye and all that [ __ ]
wicked offers yeah she she she likes
butthole that's not a secret
the guy who just could not for the life
of them wake up in the morning like he
was just not a morning person at all and
so he said it to like you know shock him
if he pushes the snooze button you know
they used to have these things for when
you win when kids were wet to bed
control know but what it would do is
like it was supposed to be an alarm went
down it wasn't like it shocked me but
obviously it's that kind of thing but it
didn't work family have money
it didn't work because I just was like
you know in a puddle of pee with this
thing going to sleep it was like a late
bloomer there's a woman that's
disgusting you love and your 6th grader
you should know better
no it's not knowing better your body
can't control it I didn't wet the bed by
the way six great huh sixth grade I'm
just saying that like Sarah Silverman
wrote a book called bed wetter and she
was talking about how she couldn't go to
sleepovers ever because like she wet the
bed and she could like they did she
didn't know how to fix it and she like
didn't choose to wet the bed that's a
small percentage well I'm just saying
okay well you know out there in the
world you shame her over here yeah
right here I think I went ahead when I
was 11 to see I've dreams that I pee but
I don't really pee in in my dream I'm
like wait I peed but then like it still
feels like I have to pee like what oh
that's good cuz that's that was my sign
of knowing that I peed in real life
oh you actually went I forgot how old I
was but I do remember waking up mid
dream that I was about to pull my pants
in the toilet or two peeing on no no no
but I actually stopped it Oh woke up and
I was like oh [ __ ] I almost beat the bed
and then I ended up going to the
bathroom cuz it really felt like I don't
know how I was able to get out of that I
always peep in my dream but it was
Beyonce there
he and then I didn't really pee that's
why I still had to pee in my dream yeah
and I'm always like do I have a UTI what
is going on in my dream I get really
logical how we good - I know how we got
to this conversation it was you would it
be yeah you yeah yeah bed wetter how
gonorrhea has nothing to do with you're
saying my husband had gonorrhea I have a
question how how shocking is this thing
like this it hurt they're doing that the
Zap strength is no more than 450 volts
so porque does that mean yeah I don't
know that's like a beacon make a pink
the type of shot that comes from rubbing
your socks on the carpet and touching a
doorknob oh that's that's pretty bad
though yeah it's shocking a Charlie get
shocked I don't know I go out but I got
shocked by an elected dryer you know
like a hair dryer the dryer and I don't
what is that like 220 I don't know what
is what's the voltage of a dryer I'm
like 450 that seems like way worse true
I don't know
or isn't it like the higher [ __ ]
like the lesser I don't know I don't
know
science science girl yeah well I'll tell
you a washer operates that exactly 365
watts per kilogram Oh we'd like to you
yeah it's like a year oh yeah it's
getting worse
nice I like it yeah we have so they're
saying you could buy these at three of
the price of $300 but they do have some
on Amazon for less $300 one time and
it's gonna curb your Bella rubber baby
what I would pay for if I was balling
his [ __ ] I would just I would just pay
someone to yell at me every time I'm
about to do some bad [ __ ] yeah about to
eat if I'm like I don't want anymore but
then if you're rich or just Pamela shut
the [ __ ] up happy no I know I hide your
face I'll pay you extra - shut up you
need to put the phone and someone else's
control like you go hey I'm gonna be
committed to this yeah then you give me
the phone and no matter what yeah I'm
not gonna give it back to you until
you're cured from the zapping cuz if you
could take it off at any time you do
have that option where you can give
someone that you trust control over the
yeah right like anybody in this room
because then you just go to the bathroom
and bite your nails
I don't know if you're fighting or no
because I would just be but I don't know
I feel like this would be a good option
for those people I really really really
want to do it they've tried everything
else and but they obviously want to do
it so this is just a help yeah it must
be something like subconscious like you
want to change cuz I think a lot of
addictions aren't really conscious right
their subconscious so that's what the
whole Pavlov's thing is is like it gets
deeper into your brain like I don't want
to do this you know they actually do
talk about that that it does stimulate a
part of your dream that has to do with
habits mm-hmm so if you're being hurt
while you're doing that particular habit
thing you have a negative association
with think I won't do it any what's
called trauma but it's like a control
tom that controlled trauma yeah because
their whole thing too is that these bad
habits that you have you can turn them
into good habits and
now that's your new habit so let's say
it like you end up smoking a lot then
instead of smoking then you work out
working out and then that's a good habit
I don't have any particular habits that
you want to kick well I guess the habit
of being lazy
- that's a pretty big cabinet and the
habit of not wanting to go work out how
does that work so if we just feel like
there's still for too long is that you I
know you've been chilling for four hours
but your watch yeah mine says that -
yeah it's judges [ __ ] cuz it's like geo
by this time you should have been doing
it whatever cuz yesterday you did it
this much at this time on my [ __ ]
charge no that's none of your business
business yeah no I turned off all those
features I'm like I don't want to be
reminded of how lazy I am even though
I'm being lazy
I'll see you just made it an enabler
instead yeah yeah I did know it sounds
like I'm just like moving my arm like
waving or something and then all of a
sudden goes you met your your activity
goal and I'm like that's all you
friendly your goal that's all you needed
to do to do is go she's in bed some
people are so lazy throughout the
country that they don't even do that so
they're like oh [ __ ] you did that okay
good you moved maybe
[Music]